silver team
on me
[Music]
i'm carlos busamante for et canada's
nerd alert halo is a sprawling space
epic whose story spans tens of millions
of years and deals with the history of
humanity itself it's conflicts with
multiple alien societies and the
creation the ultimate weapons the halo
array while that complex story is laid
out in the many books short films
cartoons and of course the wildly
popular franchise of video games the
people behind the new halo tv series
have said that their creation is a
unique take on all that claiming they
didn't actually lean that heavily on the
games for inspiration show runner
stephen kane told variety quote we
didn't talk about the game we talked
about the characters and the world while
that statement definitely raised
eyebrows among halo diehards it does
speak to the idea that the show will
explore parts of master chief's story
and character that haven't been looked
at in depth before while hopefully
keeping much of the laura fans love
intact
humanity's best weapon
master chief
huh that said there are things that we
here are definitely looking forward to
seeing come to life in the new series
first and foremost has to be the
expansion of the character john 117 aka
master chief as the lead character in
halo he is the legendary spartan hero
but aside from his origins and his
accomplishments what do we really know
about him for my producer kate all you
need to know begins and ends with the
fact that he's being played by pablo
schreiber and that he only wears a mask
like some of the time it would have been
such a shame for you to wear that whole
thing the entire time because we're like
pablo is master chief we can't hide this
man's face what was what were the
conversations like around that it was a
conversation about what was right for
the story and what we wanted to talk
about and the themes that we wanted to
attack uh you know one of the biggest
things we want to do here master chief
is a symbol right he's a symbol for for
bravery and courage under fire
having a sense of humor in the most
difficult situations so we always knew
it was going to be that it was a loaded
subject and that it was going to be
challenging for some people but at the
same time to make a television show
we knew that a huge part of our show was
going to be about the tension and the
dynamic between master chief the soldier
and john the human pablo is the perfect
actor to explore the psyche of a man who
was taken as a child and forced into
becoming a super soldier and eventually
a hero the program that produced master
chief the spartan 2 program is morally
questionable to say the least would be
interesting to see how john wrestles
with his past as he's tasked with saving
the future
what does one do with a superhuman
you're not sure you can trust
hello master chief
i'm cortana and one character who should
be by his side through all this is
master chief's ai partner cortana she
plays a pivotal role in the games and is
a huge part of halo's story we'll wait
and see how the show explores her and
john's relationship
[Music]
he and the other spartans
are our only effective weapons against
the covenant
now you can't have an action-packed
space opera without some badass aliens
and in halo it's a covenant that fits
that bill the alien lands of religious
zealots who seek to wipe out humanity
and claim the power of the halo array
it's the war between humans and the
covenant that forms a main military
conflict in the games so i'm sure the
show will give us their own version of
this group and their objectives
[Music]
finally it is halo so i want to see
master chief blowing stuff up and using
cool weapons to do it the action has
always been a huge draw for fans of the
halo games and with a reported budget of
10 million dollars per episode this baby
better deliver you can talk all you want
about the intricacies of the story and
characters but if master chief doesn't
blow up a bunch of covenant soldiers
from the back of a warthog
and i'm out what do you think what about
you do you have high expectations for
the halo tv series are you just excited
to finally be able to watch it let's
talk about it in the comments below and
call this with samantha and i'll see you
next time
[Music]
you